de ne pas respecter les règles de la
République s'agissant au fait qu'il soit
condamné il est en plus irrégulier dans
la prison donc ça nous paraît un
amendement de bon sens qui permet la
bonne coordination entre les services
deadministration pénitentièire et les
services du ministère d'intérieur et les
services du ministère d'affaires
étrangères monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis enfin l'avis de la commission avis
favorable c'est un amendement qui
apporte une plusvalue pratique règle et
je regrette avec Madame jouran de ne pas
avoir eu la ou cette idée l'abilité de
d'imaginer ce système très bien je vais
donc mettre au voie l'amendement 604 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté nous passons désormais
l'examen de l'article 10 avec TR
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 546 monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues octobre 2023 guinéen de
17 ans condamné pour agression sexuelle
sur une fillette de 6 ans récidive
auprès d'une éducatrice de prison madame
SRI lané de 43 ans condamnée en 2021
pour une agression sexuelle récidive en
septembre 20 2023 toujours pas expulsé
alors que sa précédente OQTF est devenu
caduc faute d'application un Algérien à
Toulouse âgé de 24 ans interpellé en
avril pour vol puis à nouveau les 10 et
13 juin et une dernière fois le 19 juin
pour les mêmes faits de nouveau
interpellé le 20 juin pour avoir agressé
des gens dans un supermarché jeudi
dernier un migrant guinéen à Lyon roue
de coup et viol une étudiante coréenne
quelques jours après avoir tenté de
violer une autre femme ce ne sont que
quatre exemples trois exemples de
criminels qui n'ont pas été expulsés et
qui ont récidivé agressé des Français et
surtout des Françaises je n'ai
d'ailleurs entendu aucune association
féministe et certaines sénatrices sur
ces bans eu dénoncer ces ces actes
abominables on a euh
on a le le le on a le Scand on a le
scandale sélectif et un 4e et un 4e
récent pensez-vous pensez-vous que ce
migrant guinéen pensez-vous que ce
migrant guinéen doiv absolument rester
parmi nous qu'il constitue une chance
pour notre pays pensez-vous que ce
serait abominable s'il était renvoyé
dans son pays chers collègues combien
d'entre vous serez prêt à laisser sa
femme ou sa fille pendant plus de 10
minutes en sa compagnie il n'y a aucune
raison il n'y a défendez-le camarade
défendez-le encore défendez
l'indéfendable défendez l'indéfendable
il n'y a aucune raison il n'y a aucune
raison que nous conservions sur notre
sol des criminels et des délinquants
d'autres pays si ces pays ne veulent pas
délivrer de laisser passer consulaire il
faut être prêt à engager un bras de fer
avec eux la France a récemment engagé
100 millions d'euros pour le
développement du le développement du
Nigéria le gouvernement a-t-il pris des
garanties pour qu'ils acceptent
l'intégralité des demandes de laisser
passer consula en discussion commune le
350 présenté par le président
rotaillot tout à l'heure j'ai indiqué
que les articles 9 et 10 sont très
importants les deux concernent la levée
des protections ce que j'ai appelé tout
à l'heure les exceptions à une règle qui
est affaiblie à force d'avoir été troué
justement par ces protections relatives
absolu attention parce que les deux
articles sont différents les deux
amendements que j'ai porté sont très
différents il ne concerne pas la même
nature des actes c'était les expulsions
là il s'agit des obligations sont de
quittter le territoire il ne concerne
pas les mêmes publics ce ne sont pas les
gens qui ont été condamnés ce sont
surtout des irréguliers en réalité des
étrangers en situation irrégulière et je
voudrais dire pour prévenir les
préventions si j'ose dire du du
rapporteur que au regard de
l'inconstitutionnalité on na pas du tout
les mêmes conséquence une expulsion le
recours n'est pas suspensif donc
évidemment la conséquence elle est grave
pour l'individu pour UNEF le recours est
suspensif donc il y a pas du tout du
tout la même gravité dans les
conséquences par conséquent
je pense que cet amendement devrait être
voté il est complété d'un
sous-amendement que la Commission va
présenter oui qui consiste à verrouiller
si je peux dire la sécurité juridique de
votre amendement en introduisant
conformément s du Conseil d'État la
référence à la vérification du droit au
séjour pr préalable conformément à ses
jurisprudenceces traditionnell donc
l'avis de la commission des lois vous
sera favorable et et votre avis monsieur
le rapporteur sur le 546 de Monsieur Rav
défavorable et défavorable très bien
donc si je comprends bien VI défavorable
sur le 546 et 350 sous condition
d'adoption de votre sous-amendement
absolument c'est bien ça avis du
gouvernement le le gouvernement donne un
avis défavorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur rotillot non pas parce qu'il en
refuse le principe et parce que il nous
semble qu'il ne correspond pas tout à
fait à l'avis du Conseil d'État et nos
discussions préalable même si je
comprends qu'effectivement il n'est pas
similaire à l'amendement qu'il avait
déposé sur l'article l'article 9 nous
préférons je pens ça que j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il est en discussion
commune mais ce n'est pas bien grave
madame la Présidente le 612 du
gouvernement qui lui reprend à peu près
les mêmes termes de façon un peu
différente si je dire monsieur reillot
retire les protections et laisse
finalement le juge faire nous nous
gardons les protections pour essayer
d'être conforme à ce que nous évoquons
et puis nous mettons la gravité de la
menace bon voilà donc 6 12 est plutôt
défendu si je dire en parallèle du celui
de Monsieur rotaillot ou de Madame joura
sousamendé pour que un avis défavorable
évidemment un avis défavorable monsieur
ravier j'attire votre attention monsieur
le ministre que si l'amendement 350
rectifié est adopté avec son
sous-amendement il fait tomber
l'ensemble du de l'article c'est pour ça
que je regrettais madame la Présidente
qu' a pas discussion commune très bien
monsieur le rapporteur vous vouliez
prendre la parole non c'était pour vous
avez anticipé madame sur ce que je
souhaitais dire que chacun mesure bien
la portée de l'approbation que nous vous
suggérons de l'amendement de Monsieur
Raillot il n'y aura pas de discussion de
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui est
donc écarté comme incompatible très bien
président rotaillot explication de vote
j'accepte totalement le sous-amendement
de la commission puisque je l'ai dit
d'ailleurs et je l'ai un peu anticipé
dans la présentation de de dans la
défense de mon amendement puisque j'ai
indiqué que le public c'était vraiment
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
donc qu'on vérifie leur situation
irrégulière ça me semble être une mesure
qui au-delà du droit est de bon sens
bien donc je vais mettre au vote
l'amendement 546 de Monsieur ravier avec
un double avis défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté je vais mettre au voix
d'abord le sous-amendement de la
commission sous amendement
650 de la commission donc qui avec un
avis forcément défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour l'adoption de
ce sous-amendement qui est contre il est
adopté je suis saisie d'une demande dem
de scrutin public sur cet amendement 350
maintenant rectifié par le
sous-amendement le scrutin est donc
ouvert demandé par le groupe les
républicains
pardon
person ne demande à voter si
demande à
voter c'est bon le scrutin est donc
clos nombre de votants
342 exprimé 316 pour 24 contre 112
l'amendement est donc adopté et
il fait tomber l'ensemble des autres
amendements sur cet article et l'article
10 est donc ainsi adopté puisque réécrit
par l'amendement du Président retaillot
nous sommes sisis désormais d'un
amendement 542 présenté par Monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues au vu du nombre
d'obligations de quitter le territoire
dit au qtf ordonné chaque année 124000
en 2021 selon les juges administratifs
du Conseil d'État de l'embolie des
tribunauxministra
conséquente de et de l'explosion de
l'insécurité due à cette immigration
irrégulière sous OQTF cet amendement
réduit le délai de départ volontaire des
OQTF de moitié en passant ce délai de 30
à 15 jours nous envoyons un message de
fermeté nos compatriotes n'acceptent
plus ce délai de départ volontaire ni
les délais de recours beaucoup trop
longs car ils savent que c'est une
manière de s'évader dans la nature il se
passe le mot à l'aide des associations
et de leur communauté sur place sans
oublier bien sûr le réseau de la gauche
la procédure administrative française
devient alors une farce pour eux c'est
pour cela qu'on est passé de 22 %
d'exécution des otf en 2012 ce n'est pas
fameux déjà à 7 % en 2022 c'est
catastrophique le message doit être la
fermeté ne pas laisser au clandestins le
temps de se retourner pour organiser le
prolongement de leur clandestinité c'est
pourquoi chers collègues je vous invite
à soutenir cet amendement de bon sens
merci Monsieur R av de la Commission
merci madame le Président la Commission
ne soutiendra pas votre amendement
monsieur ravier puisque nous estimons
que au regard aujourd'hui de de la
difficulté à éloigner et bien réduire le
délai n'aura pas grand sens et qu'il
nous paraît préférable de maintenir ce
délai de départ à 30 jours en cohérence
avec les nouveaux délis qui vont être
prévu par la réforme du contentieux que
nous discuterons tout à l'heure merci
Madame la rapporteur avis du
gouvernement même avis donc je mets au
voix cet amendement 542 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il ne n'est pas adopté
nous avons ensuite deux amendements
discussion commune le 537 monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues l'interdiction de retour
sur le territoire français l'IRTF est
une décision prise par le préfet à la
suite d'une obligation de quitter le
territoire français
l'qtf dans les précédentes versions du
Code de l'entrée du séjour des étrangers
du droit d'asile les interdictions de
retour sur le territoire français
n'étaient pas soumises à la limitation
dans le temps cet amendement propose de
revenir à cette version la raison va de
soi par souci de fermeté le caractère
illimité de ces interdictions doit être
érigé en principe si on ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde et
on ne le peut pas on ne peut pas à
forcierie on ne peut à forcierie pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
plusieurs fois avec ces limites on se
lit les mains on se condamne à
recommencer toujours les mêmes
procédures un client satisfait est un
client qui revient et cela cause de la
désespérance au sein de l'administration
préfectorale qui tente par tous les
moyens d'assurer ses missions et
d'éviter le naufrage national les
articles
l613-7 et
l613-8 du code de l'entrée et du séjour
des étrangers et du droit d'asile
constituent des garanties suffisantes
d'abrogation de l'interdiction de retour
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à voter
cet amendement merci Monsieur ravi
amendement 595 du gouvernement monsieur
le
ministre cette mesure que je propose de
rajouter madame la Présidente est assez
simple il s'agit d'allonger la durée de
l'interdiction de retour de 5 à 10 ans
aujourd'hui en effet lorsque vous
expulsez quelqu'un du territoire
national vous lui mettez par ailleurs un
acte administratif qui s'appelle une iat
une interdiction de retour du territoire
national aujourd'hui elle est de 5 ans
je précise ce qu'elle concerne évidment
les personnes les plus dangereuses qui
sont sur le territoire national c'est
souvent les personnes qui sont par
exemple radicalisées qui sont inscrits
au fsprt nous avons considéré avec la
DGSI avec les services de la delpagi
donc je salue le travail quotidien
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur de
pouvoir doubler tout en respectant le
cadre constitutionnel cette interdiction
de retour du territoire national très
bien avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements merci madame le Président
deux amendements qui qui nous disent
vouloir faire preuve de fermeté il
s'avère que le premier présenter celui
de Monsieur ravier n'est pas conforme à
la directive retour contrairement à
celui du gouvernement c'est donc un avis
défavorable au premier amendement et
favorable au second très bien sur
l'amendement de Monsieur ravi avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre avis
défavorable très bien donc je vais
mettre au voix ces deux amendements
amendement 537 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
amendement 595 du gouvernement avec un
avis favorable de la commission qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est
adopté amendement 545 monsieur
ravier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ce czedda a vraiment été
rédigé à une période et par un
législateur particulièrement
bienveillant avec les étrangers ce n'est
pas un mal en soi mais c'est
difficilement entendable dans la
situation actuelle et face aux
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui autorité administrative peut
désigner comme pays de renvoi soit le
pays dont l'étranger a la nationalité
soit un autre pays pour lequel il y a un
accord bilatéral soit avec l'accord de
l'étranger tout autre pays dans lequel
il est légalement admissible si
l'étranger fait l'objet d'un renvoi du
territoire national cela fait suite à
une infraction de sa part qui justifie
la fermeté de l'État dans le but d'y
concourir cet amendement supprime le
consentement de l'étranger dans le choix
du pays de renvoi désigné par l'autorité
administrative et dans lequel il serait
légalement admissible l'État a aussi des
droits il doit s'ouvrir un champ le plus
ouvert possible pour exécuter les
décisions
d'éloignement avis la commission sur cet
amendement cette disposition sera
inconventionnelle défavorable
défavorable avis du gouvernement même
avis donc je mets au voix cet amendement
545 avec deux avis défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas